[Musique]
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des avantages nous allons
conter l'histoire les aventures
now
nous allons vous parler ce sont des
coeurs
les enfants
alors
non
mais aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on
excellent
ils sont excellents 7
vous pourrez t'on en trouver d'autres
car ceux ci nous pas réussi à apaiser ma
flux rien de plus facile
vous voyez là-bas cet ami alors nous
trouvons là autant de biscuits que nous
voudrons
[Musique]
mon
oh
[Musique]
on
où
non
maison non plus on envie d'en manger
mais pia tu donc dans cette tenue
[Musique]
je soit loué
vous buvez un trop petit coup ce n'est
pas digne de vous
comment
mais je n'arrête pas
sauf que je puis boire plus que toi
[Musique]
connard si nous allions santé
à l'auteur
[Musique]
au nord à présent que je suis prête
je veux
sonné les cloches
[Musique]
et
mon
[Musique]
non